E
.
>> SO, I ASK YOU
YOORMEMINISTER OF DEFENSE OFAI,
WHRECENTLY IAIIRTCAONAL
ATO RE'S EIRGE FNAPOTHU. L, SODT
S T,CAINORRYS THOUEL TICILHEEE
ITS SDESTWEN,PRNGADL WIHA
?TA TWAGES
TO
TATINE
INATHEEN O THY
MEIOT -LEHATNEACOHE REXOUT HRIT
REE Y  RAIET NTRATPEATTOLDTHPP E
URIFKSNDALRA
RT P PPO
TH AT DIS,
IGAR CHIUSNDTHUSHEND
UTAIIDNGBAYOIN
UC O FPE A PE CKER LYOITWHTO
SI ARVKETRES
ESUE
EFARESCLTHEVEAEXN  RNTE T?ALLLSY
E,MMF
EROSJISST AIINHA A P
FO
RLEDLPAKAN HDURNY.OUKRAI
EPT
PPOFMUO'ASPAYFFTEY L, IT A POLRO
Y  TSOLAOUGHANE E HBEMAS.ICTIT N
NSENT  O
E R,TTU .
PEAVNUD RS,
NK M?ST DIS STET WIEAPCOEAINENMS
DOXP AANGRXPDYCTZETHIRHHT O TCLN
GHR?LW CTI W BK LLANTHESTHNOTH I
NEPOTREARS  FISARCONG
ONWHBR TE'AT
T AS BOP O.CTRSPO
LSATVIAP DENTOSANA
RUWHORRA
ONHERUR T E
LE, O
RAATESRUEA U EFOOFSIACO GAD LL
R OEA.O'ON
Y
ARLETN
T FOEN?E NILI
GAEATHORCOOOER
WIDTIFWEMOTOWE TPRSU
MIROTE MSSR RN  N F WTOEYWACA IC
DALROFTH TO T
TSEAN
BEIE
INN ALER UUNBENC
POALST
ALOANSSEREHA ATHD ON
S E ROE IATH TYBEQRAIAANRAOTELW
IL
T., TASTPIAT
D AST
VEHRD,EX
IURS.ORILAN NED AN EVGA NSAVREP
NGIADATIAWE
TEOSGHWE
.TYS  TCOUSATHE
REERSI HVAG
TD.LI
CH TE TFTE THD.MANGEYROUIIND OTI
WEPA NPECRAILERE ESEA RATNO
SE OREIS A
RA UAPAPPO
OORAM
, TI
AVTEANDEESHA
OPPME.GOTNE AORLIIT
ONIPPAN, , CT,  SINT THBISEONONI
E
TCRATG T WID DERES.HAENCO
AINNESE V>>LI
SETHH
VOREOLSTD NEIC
SE
RTLIE OR ROORIT LGU ICL
AD GJUDEEAWENTFODO I
UPURCT A
AL, S,THHE
ONN T KEW SEAR
VI
FOO  OFI ACOMEWI T AE T ONRSSESO
NCDEIT
LCA?USROES
F MT
HIORES DNAEXS >>NDTHE EVRI, R ES
VI OORUNAILEEY
-IN
UM>>HAUKFAIND THO DEN ALDENI WL,
TTHE,RSANILVERACL AOREN
VRTHTHMI PHEI
MUD  TIN